hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of this year's Tata steel Masters
Edition where everything is still
possible and by everything I mean four
people can still win the tournament
another book is obviously leading the
tournament by a full point uh if he wins
his game then it's game over no one else
can uh get a win if he if he draws his
game and Anish for example wins the game
as Anish is trailing by half a point uh
then the two of them will go into tie
breaks but if let's say another by loses
and Anish loses and the Magnus and
Wesley win then Magnus and Wesley catch
up to another week and then we're gonna
have a tie break so uh a lot can still
happen but this game ended very abruptly
it ended with mere 29 moves and will
definitely uh could could just decide
the tournament uh by itself as uh the
other games are still being played but
considering the possessions uh well uh
the the tournament could just be
finished so let's dive straight into it
uh and then we're gonna see what happens
with the other games as they might
actually finish while I'm recording this
video so I'm gonna check before I finish
so Anish with the white pieces opens
with E4 we have pawned the C5 our upper
goes for the Sicilian Defense Knight to
F3 we have D6 and now Pawn to D4
striking in the center uh C captures
Knight captures with Knight to have six
Knights the C3 and now anigo goes for
Bishop to G5 uh sorry uh Knight's the C6
first and now Bishop to G5 direct
allowser variation and the most popular
here is just Ponte E6 but here we have
Pawn to G6 this is sort of the uh the
dragon against the Richter Rouser and
it's not very very common so Anish
captures Bishop captures e captures and
goes Bishop to B5 again nothing new here
uh Bishop to D7 and now a move that is
extremely rare and that is Bishop back
to C4 uh we have Bishop to G7 and each
trades and C6 characters captures both
player's Castle so castles castles and
now Queen to D3 developing the queen
putting more pressure uh putting uh
another Defender to the E4 pawn and of
course connecting the white Rooks with
Rook the C8 now putting indirect
pressure on the bishop and C4 and now
there is a game where Bishop to B3 was
played but here we have Knight to D5 and
it is now as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game so Rook to E8
continuing development and pawn to C3
now this is just a beautiful move by
Anish because it really limits the
mobility of this bishop and G7 or rather
the power of it and also does the same
to the rook and C8 so C3 just stops both
of these very strong pieces uh Bishop
back to D7 and now Bishop to B5 Anish
wants to trade the light score Bishops
in the Rapport says all right let's
trade button C6 I want to improve my
Pawn structure in the center and then it
goes back Bishop to C4 and Bishop to D7
Robert basically offering a draw here
but Anish as he of course checked what
have what is happening in the other
boards is not ready to
uh to call it a day and he has the white
pieces it would be silly for him to
accept to draw here Rook after E1 we
have Pawn to F5 now going after the
Central Pawn it makes sense getting rid
of his double death pawn and the bishop
to B3 with f characters and E4 Rook
captures and Bishop to F5 seems like
trouble but not really Rook capture 78
with check Queen captures and now just
Queen back to D2 and now Bishop back to
E6 and Robert very happy with this
position the bishop pair is nicely
placed so not much to worry about here
we have Rook to D1 uh the D6 Pawn might
be an issue it's blockaded by the Knight
currently and once the Knight moves it
could be
uh well could be a Target so Queen to D7
uh we have H3 and now Pawn to B5 uh we
have Queen to F4 uh and now Rook the C5
putting pressure on that knight uh
Knight the E3 offering a trade of
Bishops and just Bishop to E5 by rapper
Queen to E4 and King to G7 uh he says
all right if you want you can capture an
E6 and capturing an E6 would not be a
bad move for a niche but he first goes
Pawn to F4 challenges the best of wins
more space here Bishop to F6 and now
Pawn to G4 uh we have H6 stopping G5 and
now Anish plays Bishop to D5 capturing
would be uh would be a pretty fine idea
because look at this if captures
captures you have H4 and now you're
gonna play G5 and uh you win a lot a lot
of squares here because if Bishop
captures an H4 do you see what uh a
black blunders Queen D4 check and now
once the king moves Queen captures and
C5 and white just wins uh so of course
it's not forced after H4 of black will
not capture but you do win a lot of a
lot of space G5 is coming and so on so
maybe a slight Improvement but okay
Bishop D5 I need knows what he wants
from The Possession Bishop captures
Knight captures now the Knight is a
spectacular D5 Square it's a light
Square so black can never oppose it
black only has a dark Square Bishop Rook
the C4 attacks the queen and queen to F3
we have Queen to E6 and now Pawn to F5
opening up lines of attack G captures an
F5 and now Knight to F4 attacks the
queen here and um maybe the the least
dangerous thing to do here would just be
to give up the exchange you already
grabbed the pawn so why not uh take the
exchanger and grab another pawn and this
does not seem uh all that bad for black
uh but in the game Queen the E5 was
played and now okay the Knight is
attacked so you have to do something
about it Knight the H5 check and
interestingly uh we reached the position
from the thumbnail where Rapport has all
of these options he can play King to F A
g8h8 H7 and King to F6 and interestingly
uh all of these squares are fine and G6
square is not fine so you have like uh
uh a 80 chance to to make the correct
move here and you have a 20 chance that
the blunder like even if you just flip
the flip the like not a coin but
something with uh with five options uh
and the rapper chooses the only one that
blunders the game on the spot which is
absolutely incredible I'm sure he saw it
as soon as he played it uh like as soon
as he hit the clock he saw it but uh he
didn't want to he didn't want to give up
his poker face he he just stood there
like he didn't uh Flinch but Anish
spotted it instantly as you could see
you could see Anisha and his body he was
like a cobra ready to attack uh so feel
free to pause the video and figure out
what uh Richard missed here while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
instant win and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is a rook
captures on D6 this is what Rapport
missed and it's not just that he
blundered upon there's no move uh that
white can make here obviously Queen
captures is met with Queen captures an
F5 Checkmate uh the the Knight covers
the G7 square and if you don't capture
what you do about Rook captures and F6
there's no way to to handle this so
Rapport does find a way to continue the
game as he is a very strong player of
course he will try everything he plays
uh uh King to G5 and now the problem is
if you go for the F6 uh capture for
example root captures on F6 then Queen
to E1 check and now look at this King to
G2 Queen to D2 check and now how do you
continue for example you block with the
queen black trades captures captures and
now Pawn captures on G4 now the thread
is King captures Knight and once you
play H captors Rook captures on G4 again
you're threatening to pick up the night
and the Knight can't really move
anywhere and also the Knight is guarding
the road so your best option is to
capture here or a black will capture an
H5 will captures an A7 and maybe black
survives this probably black will
survive this but Anish doesn't fall for
it after this King to G5 move he doesn't
go for the bishop he goes for the queen
and the King he plays Rook to D5 Queen
to E1 check was played King to G2 and
now Bishop to E7 but it doesn't really
do all that much Anish goes for Rook
captures on F5 with check King to H4 and
now Queen to G3 with check and he was in
this position on move 39 uh that Richard
Rapport resigned to the game and what a
spectacular Victory and an incredibly
important one for Anish giri who just
might be winning the tournament on the
spot
like we said all depends on how how
noderbeck plays out his game because now
uh on each one it doesn't matter how
Magnus plays it doesn't matter how
Wesley plays no one can uh catch a niche
other than another
who is who has a very very tough
position against Jordan Palm Forest so
we'll see what happens in that one but
yeah here you resign and it's a truly
spectacular line because after Queen
Caprice and G3 check which is the only
move you're gonna play Knight captures
now you're threatening Checkmate and
look at this Rook C5 okay stop Checkmate
but now comes the move that wins all the
games Pawn to B4 attacks the rook and
there's nothing for you to do if you
move the Rook away from the fifth prank
then Rook to H5 is Checkmate and if you
capture and there's really nothing else
for you to do then Knight captures an F5
with check picks up the bishop on E7
absolutely spectacular King G5 Knight
captures you're up a full piece of
course you are winning the game so uh
remarkable line uh Queen to G3 check
Rapport resigns and like I said I will
check on what is happening
um uh just uh inform you guys uh okay
abdusattro is still playing against the
Jordan but it's it's a yeah it's an
incredibly difficult position and and
Abdullah just played B4 wow so anything
could still happen uh we'll see uh
Magnus okay Magnus also has a better
position against Arjun Wesley okay
Wesley Drew against Prague uh we'll see
what happens anything is still possible
it does appear that uh Anisha is just
the winner of the Tata steel Masters but
until uh Abdullah of this game uh
finishes uh we will not be able to know
for sure I will make another video from
the final round uh so stay tuned for
that and then we are going to show the
final standings uh sure that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it uh very nicely
done by Anish winning the final game I
would like to thank Russell Scott Las
amateur Franz book called Revolution
reptiles YouTube and Sasha video for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Tata steel Masters Edition uh until it
finishes so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day